sputnik v ist vielversprechend hallo ein
russischer impfstoff lancet schreibt 91%
wirksamkeit sind in der 3c phase
wenn ich das richtig in erinnerung habe
würden sie sagen in anbetracht dieser
lage hier her damit wenn die ema
zustimmt ja natürlich könnten stoff
immer gebrauchen aber wir haben ja jetzt
genug in der bestellung und wir werden
jetzt im zweiten und im dritten quartal
glaube ich genug impfstoff haben wir
werden ende des jahres wahrscheinlich zu
viel haben können noch etwas abgeben
aber ich bin natürlich froh dass es
weltweit es geht ja nicht nur um
deutschland und europa wir brauchen ja
weltweit impfstoff und deswegen bin ich
sehr froh dass es auch in russland auch
in asien vermutlich im stoff entwicklung
gibt die dann gut helfen denn die
pandemie ist wie der name sagt also eine
weltweite epidemie
und ich glaube es ist gut wenn wir dann
auch weltweit in allen ländern dieser
welt impfstoff zur verfügung haben er
soll da sie meldeten sich am letzten
wochenende und sagten sie würden
übrigens wie die grünen für eine note
impfstoff wirtschaft plädieren
das einzig blöde an der idee ist dass
sie zu spät kommt oder wie hätte uns das
jetzt in den letzten sechs wochen
geholfen
naja ein bisschen ist ja genau der weg
eingeschlagen worden mit dem
zusätzlichen werk in marburg das heißt
die gespräche wurden geführt alle
kapazitäten zu schaffen um zusätzlich
impfstoff zu produzieren
auch bei dem impfgipfel wurden einige
firmen angesprochen die da überlegungen
haben ist ja auch keine sache in der tat
für den moment nur allein ist wird auf
dauer seine jobs hat völlig recht
wir haben eine situation dass wir länger
impfstoff brauchen und wir brauchen
diesen impfstoff übrigens auch in der
breite und wir werden ihnen auch die
nächsten jahre brauchen möglicherweise
immer wieder angepasst wie bei der
grippe in dem sich ja neue auch andere
mutationen ergeben werden
die impfstoffhersteller haben ja es gibt
zwei variablen oder zwei unsicherheiten
die eine ist quasi das material aber das
zweite ist auch die frage mutation im
moment sieht es so aus als wird mir im
stoff ist sehr gut das ist sehr positiv
aber wir werden auch immer wieder
veränderung und anpassung bekommen
insofern glaube ich ist normal
ich würde jetzt nicht einfach sagen beim
thema impfstoff jetzt reicht schon
sondern ich würde jetzt da wirklich auf
sicherheit gehen auf vorsorge gehen
es ist in der tat so es ist eine riesen
wissenschaftliche leistung und natürlich
wird uns das impfen am ende absolut
helfen also klar das ist
ganz klar bei allem ärger des moments
aber deswegen muss ich da auch schon ein
bisschen vorausschauend gehen
das würde dann auch nicht nur über die
impfzentren geben wir müssen schauen
dass wir so viel impfstoff wie möglich
bekommen und dann auch die ärzte zu
geben an die hausärzte in den kliniken
zu haben damit auch dadurch eine art
stattfinden ist auch wichtig die ärzte
zum beispiel wichtig um auch das
vertrauen weiter zu erhöhen werden
vergessen der hausarzt hat eine ganz
andere beratungs fähigkeiten richtig
sport tv ist in den augen des
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten ein
möglicher and stock sachsen anhalt hat
kein problem damit wenn also wenn die
europäische medizin agentur sagt es ist
zuverlässig natürlich dann also ich
glaube dass da gibt es ja kein problem
das ich höre ich sogar ich würde sogar
das soll besser sein als manche
impfstoffe die vernunft haben oder die
jetzt für impfen aber da muss ich
ehrlich sagen das können nur die
fachleute beurteilen
das können wir nicht sagen erst das
genau sie haben es angesprochen
warten wir was nur gut wäre jetzt also
man bei den zulassungen ich glaube es
ist schon sehr wichtig dass wir ein sehr
zuverlässiges verfahren haben ja dass
das sicher ist es soweit
aber es fällt auch auf dass die
zulassung der impfstoffe die bei uns
später sind genau die gleichen sind wie
woanders vorher zugelassen also ich
glaube wenn man die verfahren an der
stelle sicher macht aber trotzdem zügig
ist auch allen geholfen auch da mal ein
guter hinweis entdeckt daher
tschentscher würden sie auch sagen das
ist richtig wir haben überall gesehen
dass die nutzung leistungen hinterher
immer zulassungen wurde wir aber vorher
kann man es eben nicht wissen ich bin
schon sehr zufrieden dass die arznei
würden in europa auch unsere behörden da
sehr genau hinsehen
es ist doch gut wenn es am ende sich
dann auch bestätigt es ist super wenn
sich bestätigt und wir fragen herrn sie
haben das werde ich nicht vergessen herr
pusch sie haben sich vor einem jahr in
ihrer damaligen otan pingping gewand an
den berühmten chinesischen
premierminister ministerpräsident
präsident ist er sogar entschuldigung
würden sie dem jetzt wieder einen brief
schreiben also der situation wenn die
klinikleitung somit vor ihnen sitzen und
sagen wenn wir jetzt nicht schutzgebühr
kriegen und masken kriegen dann können
wir unser personal nicht mehr guten
gewissens auf der intensivstation
arbeiten lassen sich schützen können
geht es um leben und tod ein paar sinne
des wortes und not kennt kein gebot hat
man irgendwer gesagt und das war in
meiner verzweiflung natürlich weil man
hat ja gesehen dass einzigen die das
deutschen hatten waren die chinesen und
auch auf die gefahr sich lächerlich zu
machen oder auch nach dem motto liegt da
jetzt noch ganz sauber habe ich den dann
angeschrieben haben tatsächlich auch
geantwortet dass markt von deren seite
schon durchaus eine propaganda nummer
gewesen sein sondern ich bin ich ja auch
nicht aber ein kollege von ihnen hat
mich die letzten tage gefragt airbus wo
würden sie denn jetzt hin schreiben
wendet mit dem stoff beschaffung geht
und ich weiß dass meine frau ungar in
ist dass die in ungarn natürlich da auch
wieder einen sonderweg gehen wie oft
wird nicht gut ist aber die haben jetzt
ihre bürger angeschrieben und haben den
chinesischen impfstoff im angebot die
haben den sputnik im angebot
die haben auch die anderen im angebot
das soll dann so laufen dass die leute
sich aussuchen können welchen sie denn
gerne hätten die nun nicht zusichern
dass die dann tatsächlich auch vor ort
haben also die kommen dann zum
impftermin werden angeschrieben das
läuft ein bisschen anders als bei uns
und wenn dann gesagt wird ja sie haben
bei montech bestellt haben aber nicht da
sind sie auch mit sputnik einverstanden
dann hat der mensch dann da die wahl zu
leistung hin oder her also die russen
waren ja auch nie schlechte wissenschaft
da muss man auch dazusagen also ich
finde konkurrenz belebt das geschäft wir
haben doch auch vor paar tagen noch
erlebt dass einige hersteller aus auch
ein bisschen auf der nase herumgetanzt
sind dem motto wollte das zeug denn
herkriegen wenn ich bei uns als 13
ickern hat diese unsäglichen debatten
geführt worden sind also ich setze auch
darauf dass wir mehr impfstoffe auf dem
markt sind desto mehr druck auch in
einer freien marktwirtschaft da ist sein
impfstoff dann auch in genügender menge
zu produzieren und nur populismus also
staatlichen impfstoffherstellung halte
ich wenig total nix verschafft das
machen wir sagt kann
würden sie nicken bei dem weißem putz
sagt oder sagen sie
das anders und also wenn was im lancet
veröffentlicht wird dann hat man da
schon sehr kritisch drauf geguckt und
wenn es die immer dann auch noch
tatsächlich die die wirksamkeit des
impfstoffs bestätigt würde also dann
denkt dann muss man gegenüber sputnik
aufgeschlossen sein das ist doch ganz
klar
und natürlich gilt das für den
chinesischen impfstoff genauso wenn es
eine solche bestätigung gebe jetzt hat
herr söder angesprochen dass wir
natürlich nun auch unserem strategie
sogar verändern müssen wir erst weniger
eine andere zulassung hier in
deutschland hat als durch die eben immer
würden sie sagen dass das sogar auch von
vorteil sein könnte impfen wir hier aus
ihrer sicht in deutschland die richtigen
also ich hätte auch die impfstrategie
erstmal jetzt so aufgestellt wie wir sie
im moment machen denn wir haben einfach
bei diesem virus ja eine sehr sehr
starke kopplung mit dem alter es geht ja
wirklich so und insofern finde ich
völlig richtig zuerst mal die zu impfen
die mit abstand das höchste todesrisiko
tragen jetzt ist sie ist es aber nun mit
dem astra zeneca im fluss so wie es ist
und er denke ich dann kann man den auch
pragmatisch so einsetzen
und dann denke ich natürlich zum
beispiel auch an lehrer erzieher an
leute die die die diebe vielleicht auch
dann vorziehen könnten und wo wir dann
auch sehr segensreich was machen können
also ich weiß gar nicht ob das sich im
nachhinein als so ein großes problem
herausstellen wird es weniger diese
andere zulassung haben als wir das
erwartet weil es die möglichkeit gäbe
eben menschen die mitten im leben und an
der front stehen und stehen müssen
früher zu impfen als dass nach unserem
bisherigen unserer bisherigen im freien
folge der plan wäre
frau dr schröder frage nach münster sie
haben natürlich nun auch nicht nur mit
verfolgt sondern wissen am allerbesten
wie groß die angst der menschen auch vor
diesen mutationen ist wie groß muss dann
wiederum auf der anderen seite unsere
sorge sein dass wir auch virologisch wie
karl lauterbach am beginn einer neuen
pandemie stehen oder denken sie dass das
so schlimm nicht werden wird also was
man bei diesen einfach wissen muss ist
dass viren immer gut hier viren mutieren
immer
die meisten mutationen für einen virus
sind sind nicht von vorteil für das
virus aber jetzt scheint es so zu sein
dass es sich virusvarianten
herausgebildet haben die eine einfachere
übertragbarkeit und möglicherweise auch
eine schlechtere impfstoffe wirksamkeit
haben was ihr aber noch nicht wissen das
ist von vorteil für einen virus also aus
virus nicht gedacht ist dass das was ein
virus nach vorne bringt und je mehr sich
viren verbreiten desto mehr werden sie
auch mutieren und deswegen muss man
darauf achten dass die kontakte so wenig
wie möglich sind dass wir im wettlauf
mit den mutationen dass uns da nicht die
puste ausgeht und so viel wie es
irgendwie geht impfen
aktuell haben wir noch eine relativ
unklare lage was diese neuen mutationen
betrifft da ist es im moment so dass
ganz viele der labore so eine sogenannte
target pcr machen die also darauf
speziell zielt auf diese drei mutationen
die uns jetzt näher bekannt sind und
zwar die brasilianische südafrikanische
und die englische variante sind wird
gern dass es noch keine sequenzierung
dass es erst mal noch eine tage pca das
geht etwas schneller sequenzierung ist
der nächste schritt
und ich würde gerne einmal darauf
eingehen was das für uns für eine
auswirkung hat und zwar am beispiel von
der b17 mutante die wir aus
großbritannien kennen also daran sieht
man dass die sich wesentlich leichter
verbreitet und ich würde es gerne an
einem beispiel nämlich dem erwert einmal
machen und zwar ist das so dass diese
mutante den er wert ungefähr um 0,3 0,4
erhöht wahrscheinlich das heißt bei
gleichen maßnahmen ist die leichter
übertragbar das liegt wahrscheinlich
daran dass jedes einzelne virus mehr
erkrankung also leichter die erkrankung
auslöst als das bei der variante ist die
aktuell hier kursiert und jetzt denkt
man da ja 0,3 0,4 ist das denn so viel
aber man muss einmal auf wenn man auf
den er wehrt guckt wenn sie ein eher
wert von 0,7 haben heißt das dass sich
die neue instanz zahlen pro woche
halbieren
und wenn sie da jetzt 04 drauf machen
haben sie einen institute haben sie
einsteigen die inzidenz und sind
sicherlich bei 1,1 an steigen die
fallzahlen trotz gleicher maßnahmen die
man trifft und das ist eben das problem
was wir sehen wo wir auch sorge für
haben wir sehen dass zum beispiel in
dänemark
das ist da schon so ist dass die dass
die neue variante also die englische
sich ungefähr jede woche in der fallzahl
verdoppelt die sequenzieren sehr viel
die dänen das sind ungefähr 70 prozent
die sich für das heißt wir haben da
einen sehr sehr guten überblick und die
die alte variante also die wildtyp
variante die auch hier jetzt noch im
umkreis ist die geht nach und nach
zurück und das ist eben natürlich was
was ein was ein sorgt aber an diese
mutation die impfstoff wirksamkeit ist
noch gut ist noch gut die mutation wird
sich durchsetzen das haben wir auch
schon verstanden
kristina schröder die zahlen müssen
runter sie sollen noch weiter runter sie
sollen noch unter 50 und im
wissenschaftlerinnen wie frau dr
schröder sagen sie gingen am besten
gegen null
können sie das nachvollziehen zu sagen
in der infektiologie wäre es natürlich
großartig wir hätten dieses ding gar
nicht mehr runter und das ziel hoch
attraktiv ist es ja ganz offenkundig die
frage ist was der weg dahin bedeutet und
da muss ich sagen wenn ich mir angucke
was wir jetzt schon an drastischen
maßnahmen haben und die müssten wir ja
noch mal massiv verschärfen diese
maßnahmen und wir wissen nicht wie lange
es dauert also in melbourne
beispielsweise hat man um dieses ziel zu
erreichen hat man elf wochen gebraucht
und da muss ich dann sagen das ziel ist
attraktiv aber der weg dahin da würde
ich sagen der trick teilweise dann
totalitäre züge
das ist der weg dahin dann ist die frage
wie hält man das in der no go wird
bewegung wird dann ja gesagt dann machen
wir grüne und rote zonen und aus den
roten zonen da sein dass antrag
komischer lockdown und den grünen kann
man sich frei bewegen das alles an
grenzkontrollen zwischen den landkreisen
geben also ich halte das wirklich für
einen weg der hier in der mitte europas
der in unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung so nicht
umsetzbar ist und ich finde es auch
richtig dass dieser weg nicht umsetzbar
sind ich will auch nicht in einem land
leben das versucht so etwas umzusetzen
frau schröder sie sind dran also vom
spieler da muss ich ganz klar sagen und
also was wäre wenn jetzt konkret ihre
alternative ja also das muss man mal
sagen wenn man die maßnahmen oder die
vorschläge kritisiert dann wisst ja die
frage was sind die was sind die
alternativen die auf dem tisch liegen
also wenn man sich mal anguckt wie
andere länder das gemacht haben so in
unserem umkreis ich sage mal irland
portugal england tschechien
das sind alles länder die haben die
instanzen deutlich drücken können haben
dann lockerungs strategien gemacht und
sind dann in 600 exponentielle wachstum
gekommen
und damit stellt sich natürlich die
frage was also was ist denn ihre
alternative ist die alternative zu sagen
wir machen das jetzt einfach immer
weiter so und von locker und zu locken
und dann lockern wir und dann geht's
wieder nach oben das ist das was wir im
grunde vor uns haben und wir haben jetzt
aktuell also eine art kaugummi lockdown
der sich schon ganze zeit lang zieht der
immer wieder nach geschärft wird und in
dieser doku wird strategie geht es um
einen kurzen deutlichen lockdown denn
neben dem exponentiellen wachstum was
wir kennen gibt es auch einen
exponentiellen fallzahl schrumpfung um
die fallzahlen unter die zahl von zehn
zu drücken dass eine gewisse zeit zu
halten dann teile also kleinteilig in
grüne sogenannte grüne zonen einzuteilen
und dann in diesem grünen zonen die
kontakt beschränkungen komplett lockern
zu können nach und nach und in der
jetzigen phase glaube ich das mit dem im
grunde mit dem virus zu leben aktuell
heißt ohne das virus zu leben denn die
alternativen sind einfach nicht
vorhanden lassen hat ein härterer locker
und führt dazu auch dass man schneller
wieder in richtung normalität kommen
kann
heute schauen wir hatten doch im sommer
diese niedrigen instanzen wir hatten sie
doch wir waren doch nahe null und wir
haben sie nicht halten können und ist
klar ich halte es einfach auch nicht für
realistisch ich glaube werten unendliche
kosten um dahin zu kommen und dann wird
diese phase sehr groß dass wir sie doch
nicht halten sie fragen nach
alternativen ich glaube dass wir derzeit
viele instrumente auch quasi neben der
straße liegen lassen und immer nur in
lockdown logischen denken was ist zum
beispiel mit schnelltests massenhaft
eingesetzten soviel ermöglichen könnten
als ich hier ins studium habe ich auch
mal ein schnelltest gemacht das macht
dinge möglich was ist mit mit einer app
die nicht durch einig
sozusagen paranoiden datenschutz
kastriert ist sondern die wirklich was
kann was ist mit luft reinigungsgeräten
also ich rede hier über auch über
instrumente der neuzeit ich finde dass
wir zu stark auf instrumente des
mittelalters gehen und instrumente der
neuzeit als teilweise nicht um
vernünftig einsetzen
wir gehen ganz kurz mal in die runde und
raus aus dem schröder schröder duell
herr pusch was würden sie sagen ist wie
im frau merkel sagte das ding uns
entglitten und wir müssen jetzt vor
diesen mutationen tatsächlich sorgen
haben
oder muss man ja sagen seit heute sind
sie auf der seite von jens spahn und
sagen
auf gar keinen fall sollten wir durch
den gesamten winter mit diesen harten
maschen haben geht mit diesen harten mit
diesem harten locker angehen
also ich sag mal auf der einen seite
sollte man natürlich für mutationen vor
allen dingen wenn sich herausstellen
sollte dass der impfstoff dann weniger
wirksamkeit hat großen respekt haben
also das macht vielleicht vor weg
geschickt aber man wird ja sofort
manchmal hat man den eindruck einer
diskussion wenn das wort mutation fällt
dann ist ein denkverbot dann darfst du
schon nichts mehr sagen von wegen
lockerungen dann müsste schon derjenige
der es die leute umbringen will
sag mal bei spitz gesagt ich glaube aber
dass für eine verantwortungsvolle
entscheidung der politik die
verhältnismäßigkeit und die auswirkung
von maßnahmen auf die gesamte
gesellschaft zu sehen ist und auch die
die einschränkungen und die die folgen
die schweren folgen beispielsweise die
kinder und jugendlichen nicht nur cool
als gold da unvermeidbare
kollateralschäden betrachtet werden
müssen sondern wer sagt uns denn dass in
10 oder 15 jahren historiker mal auf die
situation jetzt gucken um von kobe 19
die rede ist sondern danis gesagt das
ist die zeit wo sich bei kindern ein
lock down syndrom entwickelt hat das bis
heute unsere gesellschaft beeinflusst
und bis heute dafür sorgt dass kinder
nicht normal sich entwickelt haben
ja also will damit sagen ich kann das
wissenschaftlich absolut verstehen
natürlich niedriger die fallzahlen sind
das aber im kreis vechta auch
praktiziert desto sich auch kann man
sich tendenziell fühlen und desto
geschützt da ist man natürlich auch vor
vor allem mutanten von denen übrigens
glaube ich 4000 mittlerweile gibt ja
also ob die alle schon davor stehen weiß
ich auch nicht
aber ich finde bei einer
verantwortungsvollen entscheidung beim
verhältnismäßigkeit muss der staat auch
und das ist ja das ist die frau schröder
hier gerade sagte auch die anderen
folgen für wirtschaft für kinder für
familien im blick haben und wir haben es
schon ziemlich verdammt lang lockdown in
der
der erlebniswelt eines kindes reden wir
mal über neben ihm ein paar wochen für
den ist es das gefühlt ein halbes jahr
oder ein ganzes jahr und kion forscher
sagen mittlerweile bei den kindern
verändert sich dass die kindliche
neugier das ist nicht sozial verhalten
teilweise irreparabel bestimmte nerven
gar nicht mehr angesprochen werden das
verstehe ich als laie so und auch nicht
mehr ohne weiteres dann aktiviert werden
können
und das müssen wir bei der ganz
betrachtung wenn man dann über
fallzahlen reden
die fünfziger instanz ist ja im grunde
noch mal ein kuhhandel gewesen
die wird heute damit erklärt darüber
sind die gesundheitsämter nichts auf
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung in der
lage ich weiß wie sie dastehen natürlich
haben wir auch was dazugelernt bei der
kontaktperson nachverfolgung und da
kommt vor allem darauf an wie es die
bevölkerung bereit mitzuarbeiten
wenn man jetzt aber die bevölkerung nur
mit fallzahlen kommen das ist für die
kein realistisches ziel wo die bereit
sind einfach nur zu sagen
für uns ist das jetzt wichtig wir
verzichten auf unser normales leben
gelassen unsere kinder weiter zu hause
weil wir müssen hier auf die kogit 0
strategie fahren
das ist nichts wo ich meine leute vor
ort mit motiviert kriegen würde die
beiden politiker sehen dran und ich
stelle die identische frage herr
tschentscher sind sie heute überzeugt
dass frau merkel eine wahrheit
ausgesprochen hat als sie sagte das ding
droht uns zu entgleiten oder es ist uns
entglitten
oder sind sie heute mehr bei ihren
sparen der sagt wir dürfen nicht bei
diesem harten lockdown bleiben bis zum
ende des winters also ich finde erst mal
dass wir jetzt in einer wieder
stabileren lage sind die zahlen gehen
langsam aber stetig zurück
und das ist erst mal eine gute nachricht
wir haben es gerade gehört dass es nicht
nur in rheine so dass die krankenhäuser
entlastung sehen auch bei uns die zahlen
der stationären fälle der
intensivstation gehen schrittweise
zurück
aber wir wissen momentan noch nicht wie
die mutation sich überhaupt in
deutschland schon befinden dazu und die
vereinbarung war die haben wir mitte
januar extra getroffen dass wir jetzt
erst einmal klarheit darüber herstellen
durch die sequenzierung oder diese
speziellen pc erst die es gibt wie viele
mutationen haben wir tatsächlich schon
in deutschland und wo befinden sie sich
und wie wirken sie sich aus wir sind
nämlich mit dem r faktor den frau
schröter gerade erläutert hat so knapp
unter 1 das ist eben zu wenig spielraum
dafür dass wir jetzt größere lockerungen
uns erlauben können
und ich gebe ja ein recht die sagen das
ist für die familien vor allem für die
für die kleinen kinder eine der größten
belastungen
derzeit haben kann aber es hilft ja
nichts jetzt in eine noch schwierigere
lage zu kommen um dann kurzzeitige
lockerung sofort wieder zu nehmen sie
müssen wir sind uns alle einig wenn wir
lockerungen machen dann sind wir als
erstes bei den kitas und grundschulen
ich glaube das sagen mittlerweile alle
auch das robert-koch-institut hat jetzt
so eine art stufen konzept vorgelegt und
gesagt da kann man dann auch früher
beginnen und insofern ist jetzt wirklich
die frage ab wann trauen wir uns zu
diesen ersten schritt zu machen
ich sehe in der zeit nicht finde wir
müssen jetzt erst eine expertin blick
haben auf die verbreitung der mutation
und wie sie sich in deutschland schon
auswirkt wie sie sich schon auswirkt wie
sehr sie auch bei uns schon das bild
bestimmt jetzt haben wir uns gemerkt
herr changer ich fand es interessant zu
lesen dass ausgerechnet sie dafür
plädiert haben dass in diesen
expertenrat weil der bundeskanzlerin der
klaus stöhr mit ihn eingeladen werden
sollte ein biologe der lange die whu
raten hat und eine ganz andere
auffassung grundsätzlich zur bekämpfung
dieses virus hat ich glaube es soll man
solche leute nicht dann noch einladen
dass sie eine bestimmte auffassung
vertreten und wenn man die sehen will
dann lebt man sie ein und sonst hält man
sie raus ich finde soll sie für
inkludiert ist natürlicherweise ich habe
zunächst einmal gesagt wir bräuchten
auch einmal ein epidemiologen wir haben
mathematiker physiker kluge virologen
wir uns genau erklären auch wie das
virus sich verändert was es mit dem
mutation auf sich hat aber wir sind ja
eigentlich in einer epidemie und haben
bisher keine guten einschätzung von
epidemiologen in unseren
expertenanhörungen gehabt nun hatten wir
den herrn gérard krause aus dem zentrum
aus dem helmholtz zentrum der auch ein
kluger epidemiologe ist und er genau mit
diesen fragen umgeht die wir jetzt
gerade ansprechend wie gehen wir denn
eigentlich insgesamt jetzt in dieser
situation weiter vor
und ich finde es sehr wichtig dass man
ein diskurs hat dass man argumente und
gegenargumente abwägt damit wir dann in
der politik
aus meiner sicht eben daneben
vorsichtigen den sichersten weg wählen
wir merken uns weil ich habe mir auch
gemerkt was die kritik von gérard krause
war darüber reden wir gleich das ist
nämlich ein
blick noch mal auf die zahlen in den
alten und pflegeheimen also auf die
genau dann wenn ich das sagen darf die
epidemiologen haben sehr früh darauf
hingewiesen dass wir auf die
senioreneinrichtung achten müssen dass
wir so früh wie möglich mit dem
schnelltest beginnen müssen ich glaube
da sind wirklich gesichtspunkte in einer
phase zu kurz gekommen nachdem merkel
und zu wenig breite hat auch in den
experten einig wir sind bei markus söder
und fragen uns und sie hat ihnen denn
zusätzliche expertenrat gefehlt
das könnte aber in den skat rücken ich
tippe mal sie sagen ja haben sie
irgendeine erklärung dafür warum jens
spahn ausgerechnet jetzt in dieser
situation sagt nicht diese harte
lockdown bis zum ende des winters das
ist neu die kanzlerin 31 jobs dagegen
kannst alles ich will nochmals zu der
ausgangslage zurück wie sie gestellt
haben
ich glaube wir es ist nicht den klippen
wir haben es jetzt wieder unter
kontrolle
also ich habe verständnis dass das
stresst ich habe verständnis dass das
nervt auch dass viele wirtschaftliche
existenzen massiv betroffen sind also
jeden der sich ärgern über corona habe
ich volles verständnis und jeden der
sich wünscht dass das so schnell wie
möglich vorbei ist umso mehr ich auch
bis hin zu der tatsache dass man endlich
mal wieder zum friseur gehen kann
da hat der change einen entspannteren
weg ich merke es bei mir ziemlich
eindeutig habe ich volles verständnis
dafür aber was ist die realität
alle anderen strategien die immer wieder
diskutiert werden die wir auch im
bundestag im landtag diskutiert hat die
fdp eine fülle solcher vorschläge
gemacht haben alle nicht funktioniert
das einzige was weltweit funktioniert
hat und australien ist übrigens kein
totalitäres land ohne freiheitlich
demokratische ordnung die einzige
strategie war kontakt herunter mobilität
oder ja ja ist auch richtig
das würde dann die frage der grenzen in
europa stellt aber alles hat nur
funktioniert was ihr getan werden
beispiel bayern
wir lagen zeitweise auf platz zwei in
der inzidenz mit über 200 17
jetzt liegen heute bei 83 auf platz 9
und haben heute mal die tolle nachricht
dass münchen unter 50 ist ja aber die
frage ist doch jetzt wir können doch
jetzt nicht einfach mittendrin in der
therapie abbrechen
wo soll ich was bedeutet es eigentlich
unterstation tschentscher voll da wir
den satz zu sagen weil es jetzt schon da
wurde jetzt viel gesagt und
über opfer und schwierigkeiten die opfer
der pandemie sind zunächst einmal die
menschen die verstorben sind und es ist
der schutz und die und die solidarität
der generationen ganz entscheidend wenn
wir jetzt wir werden natürlich
perspektiven entwickeln ist doch klar
und wenn die instanzen weiter runter
gehen natürlich wird sich dann die
situation verbessern und verändern
aber man könne doch nicht sagen dass wir
jetzt gerade in der situation jetzt den
wissenschaftlichen rat wieder ausblenden
ignorieren ganz anders lösen wir jetzt
endlich politische trend bietet es dafür
noch sagen ich warte dringend ich werde
dringend dazu jetzt vorsicht klugheit
und weitsicht zu haben
denn immer dieses schnelle vorzeitige
abbrechen wird uns am ende genau dazu
führen dass wir wie in anderen
europäischen ländern
dann möglicherweise ein drittel lockdown
in kürzester zeit machen müssen und auch
die wirtschaft plädiert dafür nachhaltig
konsequent jetzt wie im frühjahr
so dass wir dann auch eine längere zeit
die dann eben durch dass diese vorlagen
überbrückt werden verlässlich bis zu den
impfstoffen führt so wir sind aber noch
mal ärger weil die instanzen ging runter
und die zahl der toten waren überhaupt
nicht wirklich niedrig also nicht
überall bedeutete eine untergehende
incidents das automatisch weniger tote
zu beklagen waren das waren 1900 zahlen
pro tag herr pusch wir sind noch mal bei
ihrem punkt wie ist die situation bei
ihnen in den krankenhäusern wie sieht es
in den krankenhäusern und in den alten
und pflegeheimen aus also wir haben
schon in der ersten welle damals hatte
eine sehr fähige gesundheitsamtsleiterin
schon damals gesagt wir müssen in die
altenpflegeheime reingehen und einmal
rein testung machen das haben wir sehr
früh gemacht weil uns klar war dass
diese wohl haben einrichtungen sowohl
vom alltag der insassen wie auch von der
gesundheitlichen situation her natürlich
und sehr viele menschen dann auf dem
engen raum sehr gefährdet sind
und da haben wir glaube ich versäumt
auch durch entsprechend strategien durch
test strategien früher dafür mehr
sicherheit zu sorgen das ist ansatzweise
gelungen mittlerweile sind auch einen
deutlichen schritt weiter und da sind
wir auch mit der impfung jetzt fast
durch muss man ja auch sagen also wir
können ja nicht so tun als wenn wir
quasi in derselben lage wären wir jetzt
vor weihnachten oder in derselben lage
wären wie im bei der ersten
sondern man muss ja auch mal die
positiven signale sehen das aus meiner
sicht wenn man ende februar haben sie
auch sehr überzeugend gesagt frau
schröder die krankenhäuser das danken
das verkaufspersonal das pflegepersonal
die alten leute durch geimpft sind wie
auch eine ganz andere ausgangssituation
ja eigentlich in sichtweite haben klar
das was wir hatten 50 prozent der
menschen bei ihnen reicht das pflegeheim
und verstorben sind und das ist ja fast
etwas positives ist werden wir jetzt
hier müssen dass nicht wir müssen nicht
schwarz und weiß sehen ich habe ja auch
gesagt es geht auch nicht darum jetzt
die das vielleicht unterstellt wird
jetzt zu sagen wir machen jetzt alles
mal von heute auf morgen wieder auf ich
finde wir müssen mit intelligenten
strategien zum beispiel wechsel
unterricht in den grundschulen
ermöglichen dass die kinder zumal wir an
der lehrerin sehen es geht ja nicht
darum die klassen direkt wieder voll zu
machen und wir lieben uns ja ein
bisschen was auch in die tasche wir
haben ja jetzt eine betreuungssituation
beispielsweise nordrhein westfalen wo
die kindergärten da ist es ist
eigentlich eine notbetreuung ist bei den
eltern überlassen ihre kinder dahin zu
bringen wo die teilweise sind 80 90
prozent ihrer arbeiten sind in den
zahlen jetzt schon mit drin
also das ist ja nicht mehr die
notbetreuung wird im frühjahr hatten
systemrelevante beruf und dergleichen
und in den schulen findet ihr auch eine
notbetreuung statt das heißt das sind
auch gruppen und ihn zunehmend mehr und
sie werden erleben
immer mehr eltern denken darüber nach
jetzt auch ihre kinder wieder in diese
notbetreuung zu geben war sich vermeiden
will wir müssen wirklich vor ort gucken
und das kann man ja durchaus auch mit
einem mit einem stufenmodell oder
gleichen steuern dass wir den menschen
erstens eine perspektive bieten die
perspektive wir müssen jetzt nur witt
haben und wir müssen jetzt unter dieser
zahlen kommen ist für die abstrakte
größe denn wir sind sie auch bei der
ganzen kontaktpersonen nachverfolgen
darauf angewiesen dass die leute
mitarbeiten und motiviert sind und wenn
die dann den kopf in den sand stecken
weil die sagen die police politik hat
entschieden
wir fahren jetzt das so lange weiter bis
man quasi kein coup fall mehr
feststellen
dann werden die uns auf der anderen
ebene wobei containment machen müssen
unser gleichen vielleicht ihre
bereitschaft versagen hier ist aber
trotzdem noch
die perspektive ist wichtig ich habe mit
meiner frage gemerkt ich wollte von
ihnen wissen wie die situation in den
alten und pflegeheimen ist wie viele
fälle hatten sie da und wie viele
menschen sind adäquat zu denen wir haben
freundlich überhaupt von den 270 welche
das riecht im kopf habe 250 todesfällen
über zurzeit haben 125 aus
altenpflegeheim also das ist dass der
hohe zahl fast die hälfte
amanda und sogar noch deutlich höher ja
und das ist natürlich was was einem zu
denken gibt dass man sich dann auch die
frage gestellt haben wir in unserer
strategie die alle lebensbereiche
erfasst wo er wirklich auch erstmal so
dem dicken hammer wie sagte mal jemand
auf alles drauf gehauen worden ist
hätten wir da nicht beizeiten vielleicht
die alte 80 20 regel anwenden müssen
dass man mit 20 prozent und 80 prozent
der anstrengung die man aber besser
kanalisiert hätte vielleicht ein höheres
besseres ergebnis erzielt zu wir sind
noch mal bei den beiden außenbezirken
einmal frau schröder es wurde immer
gesagt wir können diese risikogruppen
nicht zu hundert prozent schützen wurde
hochgerechnet sind 30 millionen sind
risikogruppen die frage ein bisschen
umgewandelt 60 bis 70 prozent zu
schützen wäre ja aber auch schon ganz
schön gewesen
das wäre was also ich glaube da hat sich
wirklich ein dogma verselbstständigt
also im märz april wurde gesagt wenn wir
die risikogruppen die die können wir
nicht schützen wenn die gesamt incidents
hoch ist und ich war ja vor allen dingen
auch im märz/april sicherlich auch was
dran
wer zum beispiel mittel wie schnell test
noch gar nicht zur hand hatten
das hat sich dann aber umgedreht dass
man quasi gesagt hat wir machen nichts
besonderes für die alten und pflegeheime
sondern kümmern uns nur um die gesamt
incident und das war sicherlich auch
falsch sondern natürlich muss man beides
machen man muss versuchen die incident
zu sinken zu senken man muss aber auch
sich um die altenpflege haben ganz
besonders kümmern oder muss
flächendeckend der grundsatz gelten ohne
schnelltest darf man die nicht betreten
jetzt haben wir doch die mittel an der
hand
jetzt müssen wir sie doch auch nutzen
und dann wird auch endlich die
bundeswehr eingesetzt wenn es irgendwie
nicht anders zu organisieren ist herr
tschentscher hat gerade schon mit viel
werft dar eingesprochen
es kann natürlich einen diese rechnung
mit den incidence fällen die kann
natürlich durch den ausbruch in einem
altenheim
natürlich bestimmt und riesig verändert
werden nochmal wie konnte es sein dass
uns ausgerechnet die alten in den
pflege- und altenheimen dann am ende
doch aus dem blick gerieten
das sind keine schönen zahlen da wir
haben zu spät schnelltest wir hatten ja
erst ende oktober dann wirklich diese
schnelltest zur verfügung und dann ist
das der anstieg der gesamt incidence
dazugekommen im november im dezember und
dann haben wir sozusagen diesen wettlauf
gegen die zeit verloren wir haben dann
ja
im dezember dann auch die pflicht zur
testung von besucherinnen und besuchern
eingeführt und jetzt haben wir zwar in
den seniorenheimen die meisten geimpft
aber es sind ja noch sehr viele
hochbetagte über 80 jährigen die noch
nicht geimpft sind die nicht im
seniorenheim lehrern die zu hause
gepflegt werden
das sind aber auch ältere menschen die
sehr leicht dann wieder bei einer beim
anstich der inzidenz der schwerkranken
und dann auch wieder in den
krankenhäusern sind ich glaube auch
daran müssen wir denken jetzt ist gerade
ein stück weit entlastung erkennbar
wir haben immer noch viele
intensivpatienten aber ich glaube frau
schüler aus rheine sie hatten das gesagt
wenn da jetzt noch mal wieder etwas
drauf kommt dann ist das also eine eine
wie soll denn das personal das dann
immer noch weitermachen also nicht in
dem modern sondern in dem sprint und
deswegen sind wir wirklich in einer
phase wo wir jetzt stabiler sind wir
sehen jetzt wir haben die sache
einigermaßen jetzt im griff wenn sie
jetzt zu unvorsichtig sind dann fallen
wir sehr stark zurück und sehen wieder
an neuen stellen probleme dann nicht so
schnell regeln brechen zwischen
hingestellt
wir können ja zurzeit immer noch gar
nicht beurteilen wie welche maßnahme
sich konkret auf das infektionsgeschehen
auswirkt also der henrik hat am anfang
mal gesagt ihr habt schade dass ihr in
heinsberg sofort alles nicht gemacht
habt wir können gar nicht braucht ein
welche maßnahme wirkt wie und ich wehre
mich ein bisschen dagegen dass man auf
der einen seite nicht mal sagen kann
welche maßnahme wirkt wie und dann auf
der anderen seite aber sagt ja also
dicker hammer muss auf jeden fall
weiterkommen
es geht ja auch nicht um unvorsichtig
tschentscher es geht ja darum dass man
jetzt mit augenmaß und mit auch nicht
von vornherein wieder alles aufreißen
sondern sich das sehr genau auch vor ort
wir sind ja alles als als
gesundheitsämter vor ort sowieso auch
immer vor der viele dinge verantwortlich
anguckt welchen einfluss haben
vorsichtige lockerung beispielsweise in
den grundschulen in den kindergärten
auch das infektionsgeschehen vor ort und
stellt man dann fest so ehrlich muss man
nicht auch machen das muss man aber auch
kommunizieren dass das leute uns aus dem
ruder
dann muss man auch den leuten erklären
wir machen jetzt wieder zu aber wir
haben ja mal ein ganzer
erwartungshaltung gesprochen ich glaube
wir fallen immer mit ihm das kind mit
dem bade aus ja entweder signalisiert
man den leuten ihr könnt wieder normal
alles machen oder ob mir signalisieren
den leuten jetzt ist die nächste buch
prozession an gesagt wir müssen jetzt
alle wieder in sack und asche gehen wir
müssen
die den die füße stillhalten der
mittelweg für ihn interessante seite weg
eine antwort mit ihrer handtasche
wir haben schon erfahrungswerte wir
wissen dass die ihre sohle schwierig
sind und dass wir so aber jetzt haben
wir eine neue lage wolle mutationen gibt
wo die viren vielleicht infektiöser sind
und vieles was wir an erfahrungswerten
haben nicht mehr so gilt wie noch bisher
und deswegen ist mir sehr wichtig dass
die experten uns dazu eine einschätzung
geben wie viele mutationen haben wir
schon vielleicht steckt ja schon einiges
drin in dem jetzigen erwert wo wir noch
gar nicht wissen dass die mutation schon
dabei
und das zweite ist dann wirklich die
frage mit welchen maßnahmen können wir
dann dieses stabilität erhalten
mein gefühl ist einfach wir sind sehr
sehr langsam unterwegs in diese 50er
grenze und wir sollten nicht so bald wir
sie erreicht haben
die lockerung beschließen und dann sind
wir wieder auf dem weg richtung oder wie
gesagt da ist und nicht was war sehr
schwer also kein mensch will doch alles
auf machen sobald wir die kämpfen sich
aber ich finde wir müssen schon mal
darüber reden
er pusht sie haben es eben den dicken
hammer genannt was dieser dicker hammer
auch bedeutet also wir müssen sehen was
ist für die schüler bedeutet jetzt
teilweise seit monaten keinen unterricht
hatten und bei den älteren heißt es ja
jetzt schon wo es dann wird da auch
nicht viel passieren
wie geht es meiner altersgruppe wo die
wo die entscheidenden
entwicklungsimpulse die kommen nicht von
den eltern die kommen von den
gleichaltrigen das nehmen wir hin über
monate wir haben bei den
gewerbetreibenden zehntausende
wahrscheinlich hunderttausende die vor
den trümmern ihrer existenz stehen das
kann auch der staat nicht dauerhaft
alles abfedern und die wir hören dass
die dass die anorexie magersucht bei den
jugendlichen ansteigt wir wissen dass
magersucht eine krankheit ist die in 10
5 bis 15 zum tod führt also tun wir doch
nicht so als sei quasi ging es bei dem
lockdown maßnahmen darum leben zu retten
auf der anderen seite stunde ökonomische
interessen wir haben auch weil auch der
lok drink menschliches leid mit sich und
bringt ein menschliches leid für kinder
für für jugendliche mit sich und
bedeutet wahrscheinlich auch tote
und jetzt ist nochmal frau schröder dran
und dann sind wir wieder in münchen
also ich würde gerne einmal ganz kurz
zurückgehen zu dem thema das wir im
sommer fast die fast die null erreicht
hatten richtig das war
und da haben wir die reisebeschränkungen
nicht so gehabt und aus dem grund sind
die zahlen dann wieder dann wieder hoch
gegangen und das ist auch so in anderen
ländern ist auch erreicht worden geht es
in die richtung finnland auch keine
diktatur da ist auch noch kalt vietnam
auch keine insel was ist aber wichtig
finde ist einmal wo sie das thema
schulen ansprechen das ist mir ein ganz
wichtiger punkt den ich gerne ansprechen
möchte und zwar glaube ich grundsätzlich
dass politiker besser sind als ihr ruf
ich glaube das ist schwierig und ich
glaube das müssen alle faktoren
abgewogen werden die schulen das wie des
virus alle diese themen müssen abgewogen
werden aber bei den kultusministern da
bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher ob die
besser sind als ihr ruf weil die
diskussion die wir die ganze zeit
geführt haben und es war im grunde eine
scheindiskussion ist sind kinder
infektiös oder sind kinder nicht
infektiös findet das infektionsgeschehen
statt und es gibt zwei gründen und die
sind mit ganz wichtig zu sagen
in den schulen findet
infektionsgeschehen stadt auch schon in
den grundschulen und das kann ich ihnen
sagen aus der zusammenschau aller
studien und natürlich werden sie auch
mal eine studie die studie finden wo man
sagt ja grundschulen kinder sind
vielleicht nicht so infektiös aber es
geht um die zusammenschau und da ist
hochrelevant sagen weil die
anschnallpflicht die machen sie auch
nicht erst ab tempo 100 sondern auch
schon bei tempo 30 also auch diese
kinder sind schützenswert und
präsenzunterricht ist nicht die lösung
von allem und das fernbleiben von kita
und schule ist auch nicht primär
traumatisierend für kinder nicht
zwingend und was eben auch wichtig ist
der eine punkt ist die schuld die die
studienlage sieht so aus und zweitens
sämtliche atemwegsinfektionen sind auch
so dass die in kitas und schulen umgehen
dass sie dann die eltern anstecken und
die eltern werden üblicherweise schwerer
krank als die kinder das ist natürlich
das sind das banale infekte
aber trotzdem gibt es überhaupt kein
kunde keinen grund warum kurbelt das
ausschließen sollte also das gibt
überhaupt keinen grund warum das da
anders sein sollte
und deswegen muss die diskussion auch
ganz anders laufen die darf gar nicht
laufen schule auf oder schule zu es muss
sein schule sicher und wie können
konzepte gestaltet werden und es gibt
aktuell einen brief an die
bundeskanzlerin mit den über 20
elternvertretungen und lehrer
vertretungen unterschrieben haben und
die haben sich ganz klar für ein
sicheres konsequentes schulkonzept
ausgesprochen zum beispiel im oktober
hat das rp schon vorgaben
aus gegebenem anlass machen kann dieses
liegt alles auf dem tisch und eben auch
um das thema distanz unterricht dass das
auch ermöglicht werden muss auch für
eltern die das die das hinkriegen die
sagen ich möchte mein kind aber zu hause
unterrichten weil man kann auch das
thema social babbel mal angehen was was
lockerungen betrifft also dass eine
familie einen vertrag schließt quasi mit
einer anderen familie die sich beide
unterstützen und sich gegenseitig und
sich gegenseitig helfen kommunizieren
gut wir haben alles verstanden was sie
gesagt haben frau schröder und sind
damit im grunde genommen zu der frage
gekommen die jetzt im raum liegt nämlich
haben wir nur zu wählen zwischen london
und impfen oder gibt es dazwischen noch
etwas was herr pusch den dritten weg
nannte und genau diese frage möchte ich
jetzt nach münchen zu markus söder noch
mal stellen
herr söder gibt es sie haben gesagt
impfen ist die langfriststrategie nummer
eins rettet leben die drei punkte alle
nicken und sagen ja das stimmt ist
unsere einzige alternative der doktor
oder wann fangen wir unsere welchen
bedingungen an zu lockern
wir werden dann lockern können wenn die
zahlen gut sind ich glaube dass ich da
einfach nicht täuschen und auch selbst
belügen belügen wäre das das haben die
schweden gemacht das haben andere
gemacht ist am be übrigens auch getan
im november so ein bisschen zu hoffen
mit dem locker und leicht wird es
irgendwie gehen
man kann mit corona kein deal machen
selbst wenn die politische mehrheiten
dafür haben
selbst wenn alle der meinung sind es
muss so sein kroner lässt sich so nicht
steuern
also dann wenn das kontakte reduziert
werden und mobilität reduziert wird dann
funktioniert es
wir können das begleiten natürlich ist
es so dass wenn wir niedrige zahlen
haben wird es mehr möglichkeiten gibt es
das selbstverständlich hat er kein
interesse daran
natürlich wollen wir dass kinder
möglichst schnell wieder in die schule
geben dass die menschen ihre ihrer
arbeit nachgehen können die künstler
ihrer kreativität die wollten uns
überhaupt nicht angesprochen
auch eine ganz wichtige zielgruppe
natürlich wollen wir das alles aber wir
müssen genau den weg dass sicherheit
gehen denn überall war es so wenn wir zu
schnell den fehler machen abzubrechen
also unsere länder um uns herum portugal
war so auch österreich machen jetzt
wieder neu
dass sie wieder mit einer sehr hohen
inzidenz wieder solche maßnahmen
öffnungen treffen
ich kann nur eines sagen die kombination
aus einer mutation und einer
überstürzten lockerung es ist da nicht
der dritte weg das ist der schlechteste
weg weil das führt dann tatsächlich
genau wieder da wo wir standen und dann
wird die akzeptanz überhaupt nicht mehr
das zentrum ist ein leichter
vorsichtiger weg und natürlich ist es so
wenn es jetzt besser wird die zahlen
und wenn so einige landkreise auch zum
teil jetzt unter 35 sein könnten oder
noch weiter herunter
dann ist das natürlich eine andere
situation völlig klar auf eines müssen
wir aber aufpassen wenn wir da jetzt 8
19 verschiedene stufen entwickeln haben
wir umgekehrt das problem das ist zwar
differenziert wirkt aber müssen
aufpassen dass da noch jemand
durchblickt wenn zum beispiel im
landkreis landkreis direkt nebeneinander
die inzidenz sein auseinander gehen
wegen dem ausbruchsgeschehen oder warum
ständig dass zum beispiel sagen an der
grenze zu tschechien echte probleme
in tschechien hat hochwertigste in st
das bringt darüber dass springt rüber er
tirol haben heute auch gehört österreich
überlegt auf der einen seite zu öffnen
und auf der anderen seite in tirol kann
einen zur vorsicht einfach vorsicht und
dann schauen wir die lage sich
entwickelt ich bin da eh nix hat sehr
bei herrn tschentscher natürlich wollen
wir verbesserungen aber lieber einen
schritt langsamer als dann am ende ist
wieder verstolpern